lots to talk uh to Mel's dry Secretary
of State for work and pensions about
then this morning good morning good
morning it's great to see you thanks are
you a bit of a mover on the Dance Floor
you don't want to see me on the Dance
Floor I see I'm my young daughters would
concur with that okay talk to me about
what is going on with the French are we
nearing a deal with them well uh clearly
the Prime Minister has been engaged with
President mackerel and the government's
been engaged with the French government
and all sorts of different levels and my
understanding is we're in the final
stages of what could be an agreement
which would be very good news and I know
that the Prime Minister personally has
been absolutely on top of this a couple
of briefings a day in fact on the whole
crisis that we're looking at so let's
keep our fingers crossed the mood music
seems to be good at the moment and will
that involve British border Force being
posted with the French we'll have to
wait and see we'll have to wait and see
on what any detail that emerges but I
think the good thing is I think there
has been a fundamental shift in tone
between ourselves and the French and of
course that's fine
um I just think the approach of Rishi
soon has been one of close engagement I
think he's a person that gets right
across all the details so I suspect
having put a lot of personal time into
what the solutions might look like he's
probably come up with something that
might stand more chance of working and
than might otherwise be the case so
hopefully I would think the French would
see him as somebody very serious
somebody who wants to work as a close
partner in solving a problem which of
course is not good for either country
how close are we through a deal
I not actually in the room myself so I
can't comment but but certainly what is
being said is that we appear to be in
the final stages is the language that
I've heard of a special deal week's days
let's wait and see let's wait and see
but I I've no doubt that the government
is pressing on this with uh with great
Vigor
um Thriller bravman the Home Secretary
has her own view on migrants that she's
told us quite a lot about yesterday we
had the former Home Secretary Grant
chaps on the program he appeared to
throw her under the bus suggesting that
the government was in danger of breaking
the law and he changed the situation at
manston the Detention Center straight
away the first moment he got in to power
why did she not do it well I I don't
know all the ins and outs of exactly the
decisions that Sue Ella made but I do
know that the Prime Minister has
confidence in her she's made some
mistakes in the past she's apologized
for that the priority Now is really to
look forward and if you look at what has
happened in recent times things have
improved so we've gone down from 4 000
migrants at the manston center which is
massively over the capacity down to 1600
which is at the capacity so progress is
being made but I don't think anybody
would suggest there isn't still quite a
long wait no I understand that but just
to take you back to the point that I was
trying to make I mean the government
can't have been in danger of breaking
the law one day in the previous day not
well as I say I don't know all the
intricacies of all the decisions that
were taken certainly well certainly
bravaman uh I believe is is stating very
clearly that she didn't do anything that
would have been in breach of the law but
as I say what I think really matters now
is that we get on top of the situation
at manston Robert General second and the
Home Secretary have been very closely
involved now in steadying that situation
and it seems to me that in Fairly short
order after what was a huge surge of
migrants coming across the Davis Straits
they have actually started get on on top
of that and I think that's the most
important thing at the mailing now
there's a lot of more work to do as we
know working with our French partners
and other approaches to solving what is
a multi-faceted issue with migration but
it is an absolute top priority and I've
no doubt that through time we will start
to see Improvement do you acknowledge
that it would be a surprise for the um
the advice from officials to have
changed within 24 hours
well as I say I I'm not close enough to
know what the advice may or may not have
been what these circumstances on the
ground were so I can't really comment on
that other than to say that I think the
most important thing now is that we
continue to make the Kinder progress uh
that we've seen in the last week
um what sort of man is Gavin Williamson
um I think he's somebody who has some
significant strength I think he
understands government very closely he
was PPS to David Cameron when he was
prime minister so he's somebody who
would have an understanding of the
workings of the Parliamentary party and
of Parliament and know a large number of
colleagues so
um I think those are strength strengths
that Gavin has
it doesn't seem a particularly Pleasant
bloke or boss
well I actually served in the whips
office under Gavin Williamson and there
was always this great aura of you know
do you remember cranus the spider the
tarantula Etc and the reality with with
cronuses he was much touted
um but he never actually was released to
bite anybody so that was how I always
saw uh Gavin as somebody had this sort
of aura or a Mystique around him but the
reality was he just generally got on
with his job and I can only speak from
my own experience okay and that was how
I found him working for over a year that
he sends to women haven't we and we also
suggestions that he vehemently denies
that he tells somebody to Slit their
throat and somebody else to jump out of
a window well if that is the case that
that is utterly utterly unacceptable but
at the moment it is in the realm of
media speculation there is an
independent inquiry as you know going on
around another instant alleged incident
between himself and the then Chief whip
Wendy Morton and I think the important
thing we do now is not to start being
the English government minister of
hining on who's right and wrong and what
may or may not have happened but to wait
for the results of that investigation
and then when we have that and any other
investigation that may be triggered in
the meantime then I think we can take
stock and come to a phone conclusion
who's going to carry out that
investigation well the independent
parliamentary authorities so the
complaint as I understand it was made by
Wendy Morton about Sir Gavin Williams
yes at that point it was it was a party
matter because it was made to
conservative party central office and so
we'll go through that process but it
will be independent and it will be
thorough and it will come to a firm
conclusion I have no doubt and the
suggestion was that the Prime Minister
knew about it at the time and yet still
gave him a job well I understand what he
knew was that there had been a
disagreement between Wendy Morton and
Gavin Williamson but what he didn't know
was the substance of the allegation in
other words he hadn't at that point for
example seen the texts that are now out
in the Bible I'm surprised that he
wouldn't have asked to see that
well it depends I think if somebody came
to you and said look just just to let
you know prime minister these two
individuals have had a disagreement and
it's rather heated Etc uh amidst the
world of a busy day and lots of
appointments and other things going on
you might be forgiven for not
necessarily drilling down and demanding
all the detail immediately what do you
think particularly if at that point it
was as I believe it was subject of an
independent investigation that would
perhaps be further reason why you
wouldn't actually say I want to see all
the evidence what did you make of the
content of those WhatsApp messages well
unacceptable unacceptable I mean to
adopt that kind of language and that
kind of tone is clearly not acceptable
and to be fair to Gavin he has
apologized and recognized that whilst he
may have been frustrated at the time it
was inappropriate to respond it wasn't
just one particular when he was hot on
the car well as I say he he has accepted
uh that it was not the right way uh to
proceed and and I've just answered your
question very direct by saying I don't
think it was appropriate yeah is he
unsackable well I don't think anybody's
on sack well I'm not on sackable as
we've seen the recent past even prime
ministers are not unsackable so I think
the answer to that is we are We Are all
uh sackable at some point
um depending on the search I mean you're
doing really badly in the polls though
aren't you down again in the latest poll
at the 20 odd Point difference between
you and labor doesn't help when you have
people like Gavin Williamson
um in government does it really well
we've seen actually an improvement of
our position of the poll now admittedly
from a very very 48 27 yes from a very
low base I'm just going to make that
point but it is nonetheless beginning to
go in the right direction there are
several things that we've got to get
right and one of them is migration uh
there are very serious issues around the
Health Service that Steve Barclay is
working on and beginning to address and
of course there's a central issue of the
economy and we'll heal from the
chancellor on the 17th of November uh
the the fiscal plan if you like and the
Obama are forecasted around that to
settle things down and give us that
direction of travel on the economy and
my feeling is that as we start to make
progress in that area those areas we
will start to see further progress
against labor and get ourselves back
into Political contention but I do
accept that we have a very long way to
go and there's an awful lot of work to
be done I think that was your
opportunity to mention why you're here
as well this morning well yes some good
news Okay because I'm mentioned the
Chancellor's work now of course that's
going to be very tough choices around
tax and spending and lots of difficult
things that the government's going to
have to do but within that the
government's core mission is to look
after the vulnerable to make sure that
those that are less well-off are as
protected as possible from The Fallout
from the war in Ukraine on Spike in
Energy prices and so on and so that
means we're making in total 650 pound uh
payment to low-income households that's
8 million households up and down the
country and the second tranche of that
is literally going out between today and
the end of this month
it will be of a huge help to millions of
people and it is not the only thing that
we're doing of course it's part of a
much wider support package so there's a
400 pound Discount Energy bills so
there's targeted support for the
vulnerable 150 pounds so those who are
disabled 300 pounds for pensioners is
also the energy price guarantee so we're
making sure that average Energy bill
don't exceed two and a half thousand
pounds is a local Authority fund for
discretionary got it support so it's
important though this is a huge let's
talk about Boris Johnson the cop is that
a help or a hindrance well Boris is
perfectly uh entitled to go to cop as
with many concerns because I didn't see
it that way I think at the end of the
day you know he was a prime minister who
believed very strongly in the green
agenda in net zero and was incredibly
enthusiastic about the potential that
the economy has for benefiting uh from
the green technologies uh of the future
so I it doesn't surprise me uh that he's
there
um and I don't see why he shouldn't be
well he created a U-turn didn't he buy
it for our own prime minister who said
he wasn't going to go and now
um he said he wanted to concentrate on
the economy now he's decided he will go
after all when I interviewed um Rishi
sunak in the summer he told me that he's
first overseas trip would be to Ukraine
it's not so what does that say to the
people of Ukraine
well sometimes I think too much can be
set by exactly who tools to who first or
who visits country uh first one always
has to get a balance between you know
what you would ideally like to do and
what circumstances dictate I think it
was very important that he went to
Sharma Sheikh and uh he clearly did as
well because despite all the pressures
that he's under working with the
chancellor for the statement on the 17th
he has gone he has made a Major Impact
there he has underscored our commitment
uh to net Syria to delivering on the
Glasgow cop and the commitments uh that
we made then I think it was important
that he did so and I think probably
personally to him it was important that
he went to he's going to Ukraine there
isn't he
well let's see these ten knots the Amber
told us yesterday that he was well well
then it must be true let let's see uh
about that I mean visits tend to be
because of the security
um
talking about security what um what
about these stop oil protesters what
we're going to do about them
well I I do think that there's a there's
a major issue when individuals can go on
to motorways or even just outside
parliament in fact uh periodically at
will just sit down in the middle of the
road and disrupt the traffic sometimes
indeed Emergency Services get caught up
in that as well so the government is uh
moving to the point where we're having
the tools to be able to
um deal with that through legislation uh
and it will then be a case of government
working uh with the police and within
the legal framework so that we're able
to intervene in a in a more robust
manner to make sure that these kind of
things are less destructive than they
are at the moment have they got a point
though they have got a point haven't
they well they do in the sense like
there's a couple of points here okay I
think one is absolutely
um we are all determined and this
government above all else is absolutely
determined to Bear Down on the use of
fossil fuels and you can see that in the
diminished use of coal for example the
way that we have ramped up Renewables
not least offshore wind we've made huge
progress as a government and we've got
to keep that going second point I would
make is that we do have to strike the
right balance between the right of
individuals to express their opinion and
protest which is absolutely fundamental
to a civilized democracy which is what
we have in in our country and at the
other time making sure that we don't
inconvenience the public or indeed in
danger the public in some circumstances
and that's the kind of balanced approach
that the government is taking to strike
the right balance between these
particular objectives are you a football
fan I'm not hugely into what my wife
supports Liverpool so if Liverpool were
playing I do show an interest in
Liverpool but I can't say I have a local
team though what do we think about
um the uh situation in Casa we've had
several guests on over the last couple
of days saying that you know we really
shouldn't be playing there and it's
totally inappropriate the way that
people who are gay are treated in a
place like Qatar whereas James cleverley
has said the foreign secretary that we
should respect uh the rules of the
country that we're going to well I I
think you can work with the rules of the
country that you go to because that is
their law but you don't have to approve
and I know that uh registrations have
been made by the UK government to the
Qatar authorities around the issues that
you're mentioning because from my point
of view on the government's point of
view those things are wrong on the issue
of sport and politics I personally tend
to lean into believing that we should
have the sport and deal with the
politics separately and I would apply
that also to the Olympic Games and
boycotts and so on
um but you know these are serious issues
and they are issues that the government
is and has been taking up final question
before I let you go a couple of weeks
ago last Friday I was speaking to
Anne-Marie trevelyn outside Downing
Street and I said do you think this
trust will still be in power by the time
I came back from my holidays she didn't
even last the day do you think Gavin
Williamson will still be in government
by Christmas
well I'm not going to speculating on
anybody's future I suspect the answer to
that is yes because there is an
investigation that will take some time
and we've got to wait to see what comes
out of that the Prime Minister
um has made it uh clear that he's an
important member who's the cabinet we
discussed earlier some of the uh
strengths that he has and as an
individual and the important thing now
is that the the uh the cabinet which is
broadly drawn from right across the
Parliamentary party uh works together
um closely together drawing on all the
talents we we have and and Gavin is
definitely has a number of talents in
order to do the very best that we can
for the British school he's going
nowhere at a difficult time yeah I must
let you go it's always great to talk to
you thank you very much thank you uh
what are the papers saying this morning
let's have a look should we several of
them leading with the climate Summit
this morning the eye leading with the
grave climate warning at cop27 from the
UN Secretary General the male condemning
climate activists demanding the UK
should pay a trillion pounds in Damages
to poor countries affected by climate
change what's the Metro saying remarks
on the warm Rapport between Rishi sunak
and Emmanuel macron
the guardian says that poorer nations
are paying more for the climate
breakdown
and if you scan the QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
latest edition of The Sky News Daily
podcast
also coming up on the program for you
President Biden and Donald Trump have
been on the campaign Trail a final push
to urge their supporters to get out and
vote the U.S midterms could lead to an
even more divided political system the
Republicans are hoping to make big gains
at the expense of the Democrats the
rhetoric is as heated as ever with
Donald Trump laughing at Joe Biden's
Frailty and the president warning that
democracy is at risk James Matthews has
the latest from Washington
[Music]
he's enjoying this it is the incremental
comeback of Donald Trump in Ohio to
Violent music he made an announcement
about the announcement it is it seems on
I'm going to be making
a very big announcement on Tuesday
November 15th at Mar-A-Lago in Palm
Beach Florida
[Applause]
on the eve of the votes the man who
evicted him from the White House
scrolled through his phone as he flew
towards the campaign Trail
if Joe Biden was checking midterm
forecasts it might not have made for
happy reading
because opinion polls across these
United States predict success for his
Republican opponent of the two Chambers
in Congress they're took to take the
House of Representatives the race for
the Senate will be tighter the power in
America lies where it always does in
your hands the hands of the people the
president closed his campaign as he
began it with a warning of election
denying opponents who would threaten
democracy as the night ended he spoke
results and expectations the Democrats
win the half
I think it's going to be tough I think
we can I think a win to spend it I think
the house is couple
when the ball come we attack
at these elections Americans will Define
the remainder of the Biden presidency
what's important to you when you make
your vote the economy the high grocery
prices we need to do something about the
violence I have five kids so education
definitely 15. Joe Biden has carried
policy achievements in office and his
parties vote will be bolstered by a
backlash against new abortion laws
but he's weighed down by a flagging
economy and his own unpopularity a
midterm takedown would mean the hard
yards of government even harder so two
winning party backing for a second run
at the White House
these are the first national elections
since the assault on the capital two
years ago there are real fears of
violence this time particularly around
contested results when the Mist clears
on these midterms it will reveal their
reboot of the seat of power if there is
a republican Red Wave its size will
dictate the scale of change through this
presidency and the next one James
Matthews Sky News in Washington
well Joe's in Phoenix in Arizona for us
this morning hi Joe good morning to you
midterms today expecting an announcement
we're hearing from Donald Trump next
week sometime I'm guessing it all
depends how the midterms go for the
Republicans as to what he might say
exactly K and this day Arizona is a huge
test for the former U.S president
because there is a slate of trump
endorsed election denying Republican
candidates how will they do well this
devices but sort of headline grabbing
form of politics deliver will they be
able to have the momentum to get their
base to turn out or will the more
moderate Republicans and independents be
turned off by all of this if Donald
Trump does well and there is a red wave
for his at Candice that could clearly
provide momentum ahead of a possible
presidential run the big issue here as
James touched on it in his report
including across the whole country is
the economy inflation in Phoenix is at
13 the highest in the whole of these
United States voting centers opening
across the country in a matter of hours
it could be towards the end of this week
before we have a complete picture of how
much this country and its politics has
changed and K as you say next Tuesday is
the big day for this possible
announcement from Donald Trump
okay Joe for now thanks so much indeed
still to come on the program for you
today though President Biden and Donald
Trump making their final pictures ahead
of the U.S midterm elections but could
they lead to an even more divided
political system just hearing more about
that from Joe won't we we'll get the
thoughts of the U.S political
commentator Scotty Nell Hughes and the
political and women's activist Dr Shola
in light of the new challenges facing
the travel sector we'll be speaking to
Alan French the head of Thomas Cook
about what can be done to get the
industry back on its feet
and at age of five we'll speak to the
shadow Home Secretary Yvette Cooper just
hearing there from the government that a
deal is almost done with the French as
far as migration is concerned
majority of schools in England say
they'll have to make redundances next
year due to Rising costs and funding
cuts a survey of more than 11
000 School leaders found two-thirds
planned to make teaching assistants
redundant or reduce their hours the
government says it's providing over 50
billion pounds of funding to schools and
is helping with their energy costs
here's Becky
we want to invest in the children and
invest in our features however it's
impossible at the moment
in schools across the country it's
becoming increasingly difficult to make
the numbers add up we're in crisis every
school is in crisis cost of living is
going up cost of wages going up Energy
prices transport you name it it's going
up
as the cost of everything has risen
schools are being forced to make cuts at
this primary near Stafford they've
reduced the number of teaching
assistants and increased some class
sizes to 32 children
morally it's not great uh we want to do
as much as we can to support children
their education the vulnerable children
are mostly affected it's heartbreaking
[Music]
[Applause]
problem is the vast majority of school
budgets go on staff wages so the only
way to make real savings is redundancies
this head teacher from another school
has had to make that decision already
she spoke to us anonymously because she
wants her staff to enjoy Christmas
before she tells them
we're going to have to cut three senior
teachers and some support staff as well
once these Cuts have been made the
standard of Education in my school will
not be good I feel sick and I feel
horrified for the families the community
that we serve I feel very very worried
about the future
she's far from alone a survey of more
than 11 000 School leaders in England
has found the majority will have to cut
staff next year two-thirds plan to lose
teaching Assistance or reduce their
hours while half are looking at cutting
teachers or teaching hours
look what happens next unions are urging
the government to listen ahead of the
Autumn statement this month failing to
increase budgets would be catastrophic
for young people and if we really are
going to repair the damage of the
current crisis we need to invest in
young people right now
the department for Education say they
have increased funding but teachers warn
they need more or children will lose out
Becky Johnson Sky News Stafford
new figures showing a lack of trust in
the police among more than half of black
people and concern about racial
targeting in cases of stop and search
figures show that fewer than half 46
percent of black adults trust the police
as compared to 64 percent of white
adults still a low number isn't it 94
forgive me of black adults feel that
stop and searches are racially
disproportionate that compares to 72
percent of white adults but 86 of all
those questions support stop and search
if it's suspected someone's carrying a
weapon
more on this with shiman standing by
Scotland Yard for us this morning
um hi shiman good morning worrying
figures those aren't they
they are just to recap and explain a
little bit about what stock and search
actually is it's a tool that police have
which enables them to search a person if
they believe they have a reasonable
grounds to do so and it's usually used
to find weapons drugs or possessions as
a result of a burglary for example but
stop and searches being a highly
contentious issue especially for black
people for decades now as many believe
that it isn't used proportionally and
figures from last year actually Bax this
came up it shows that black people are
seven times more likely to be stopped in
search by police but that less than 15
of all soccer searches actually resulted
in an arrest so this data from the crest
advisory Think Tank really breaks down
what this means in real terms and it
found that across all ethnicities 49 of
people that have been stopped in search
had significantly less trust in police
compared to 65 that had not and whilst
black people were more likely to be
worried about crime in their communities
that were less likely to feel protected
under the law okay for now thanks very
much indigimon thank you let's tell you
about the Chinese military showing off
some of its futuristic Weaponry for all
the world to see and possibly to fear
talked about it yesterday didn't we with
um Helen Anne she is with us uh again no
wow this is a pretty funky stuff that
we're looking at Helena good morning
yeah good morning Kate uh yesterday was
the sort of getting ready day today is
the grand opening of the juhai air show
and we are in this huge exhibition that
is just Laden with the most Cutting Edge
the most exciting the most modern
examples of Chinese technology these are
jet models that we're showing you here
there was a big air display this morning
of the brand new stealth fighter jet
that the Chinese wanted to show off to
their people close up and to the world
as well it's called the j-20 they're
really excited about that I just want to
walk you over here though okay because
the reason that this uh air show is so
interesting and so exciting not least
because it's very unusual to see this
sort of Technology close up it's really
the question of what the Chinese would
ever do with it and I just want to point
you towards this screen over here it's
describes itself as future operation
concept but actually what it is is a
sort of simulated uh display of how
theoretically China could invade an
unnamed mountainous Island and of course
lots of people will look at that display
and think that the Taiwan question is
very very implicit in that and of course
coincidentally this week the UK trade
Minister Greg Hans is in Taiwan for what
he stresses are trade meetings but of
course the Chinese really bristle at
that the self-governing island the
Chinese absolutely see as it alone and
as a result there have been more Chinese
airplanes flying towards Taiwanese
airspace in the last couple of days than
at any time since August so that is
notable but absolutely the message from
the Chinese they have a strong modern
military and they want the world to know
it donating stuff thanks so much indeed
Helen and thank you looking at some of
today's other headlines for you now and
an eight-year-old girl who was allegedly
locked in a bedroom in Germany for seven
years has been freed it's claimed her
mum and grandparents kept her in a room
in their house near cologne since 2015
when the child known only as Maria was
18 months old Maria was so weak when she
was found that she could barely climb
stairs
the boundary commission has rejected sir
Gavin Williamson's argument against
merging his South Staffordshire
constituency with part of another it
means the Under Fire cabinet office
Minister may have to fight for
reselection ahead of the next general
election
hundreds of women are going to benefit
from a new breast cancer drug which
targets one of the most aggressive forms
of the disease over 1500 patients in
England with triple negative breast
cancer will be offered the drug after
officials gave the green light for NHS
use
the queen consort's new Royal Cipher has
been unveiled by Buckingham Palace
the monogram will feature on Camilla's
personal letterheads cards and Gifts the
first time it'll be seen by a large
audience in public will be when the
queen lays across endorsed with it at
the field of remembrance
California swimmer had a shark shock
when she was bitten off the coast of
Marina Del Mar uh Lynn judgment
something like that was resting in the
water during her morning ocean swim when
something rammed her heart out of the
water she says she knew immediately it
was a shark she's recovering from a bite
on her leg and gave her interview from
her hospital bed
it hurt and it pushed me up and out of
the water
and it shook once kind of like a dog and
then it let me go surprisingly I'm I'm
feeling pretty good uh I don't know if I
just haven't processed everything my
friend did send me an article that said
that I should buy a Powerball ticket
because apparently the chance of winning
the Powerball right now are less than
getting attacked by a sharks
I suppose that's true um according to
experts Meghan Trainor was right when
she said it's all about the bass
no trouble I'm all about that bass now
researchers have found that we dance
more when a song has a strong bass they
say this happens without us even
realizing scientists at McMaster
University in Canada found that when
they introduced low frequency sound at a
music event gig goers moved more even
though the sounds were not conscious
consciously detectable so she was right
after all still to come more on the U.S
midterms with our spirited Duo Scotty
and Scholar
[Music]
tomorrow is here very good morning to
you just joining us here on the
breakfast show on Sky News you've missed
the minister what did he say he said
that we are very close to making a deal
with the French about migrants after
Richie sunak and Emmanuel macron had a
very friendly looking meeting at cop27
yesterday now we have been here before
remember pretty Patel gave the French 54
million pounds last summer and that
didn't have much of an effect on migrant
Boat Crossings in fact they just
increased but Richie sunac is hopeful
that there'll be a deal whereby perhaps
the British border force can sit in the
control rooms on the French Coast
anything that could be done to try and
stem this would be the government's
priority but we'll see whether it
actually happens in that way what about
the bloke Gavin Williamson what does he
think of him well really really shocking
allegations in the guardian today that
Gavin Williamson told a senior civil
servant to Slit your throat and on a
separate occasion to jump out of the
window this civil servant alleges that
they were mean and intimidated by Mr
Williamson this is where he denies the
allegations secretary yes a few years
ago he denies all of this he says he
completely denies it and the civil
servant made a complaint to the HR
department at the ministry of Defense
but did not take it further up than that
but really adding to the impression that
Gavin Williamson was someone who was not
just to fellow MPS when he was cajoling
to vote but even to his civil servants
uh with someone who behaved in an
unacceptable way according to these
allegations so we'll see if there's more
to come on that but really adding to
pressure unless you see next judgment
yeah indeed so and we'll talk about that
in more detail in the next hour and also
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock looking
forward to that thanks very much indeed
of course prime minister presently at
cop 27 trying to do a deal there as well
which is where he was with President
macron so a quick look at our climate
dashboard should we World Experience
extreme weather conditions this is what
our dashboard is showing you right now
the right half of the screen shows how
the UK's power is currently being
produced on the top left you can see how
much warmer the Earth is now than in
1880 that's when modern record keeping
began and finally the bottom left the
total amount of CO2 emissions in
millions of times you can see we're
using 52 and a half percent of
Renewables at the moment no coal
whatsoever
now Jamaica is one of the island
paradise is threatened by climate change
rising sea levels unpredictable weather
patterns threatens its excuse me number
one industry which of course is tourism
the minister for tourism Edmund Bartlett
is with me now good morning to you it's
great to see you again thank you so much
for joining us how worried are you about
climate change
oh well we recognize that the big
elephant in the room for tourism is
climate change
tourism is really uh influence hugely by
the environment which is this product
that's what we do so with any kind of a
threat
to the stability of the order it's a
threat to tourism and a threat to
tourism is a threat to countries like
Jamaica that are hugely dependent on
tourism flows for its economic
well-being we've been hearing from the
Prime Minister of Barbados he's been
speaking at cop27 I'm sure you're aware
he talked about uh she she forgive me of
course it's a she forgive me how
embarrassing richer countries have
achieved what they've achieved at the
expense of countries like yours and also
uh Barbados
um what did you make of her comments
well I think that time I never comment
on you know Partners in the Caribbean I
think the issues however are broader
than that especially coming out of the
pandemic
which has really put a a new spin on
human existence on planet Earth and has
called for a greater sense of
collaboration and understanding of
shared responsibilities on what we have
to do so I think that old rhetoric has
to change somewhat to look at how do we
collaborate better and Captain 27 should
be that venue where the strongest
statement of what is made about shared
responsibility
when the earth gets warmer it destroys
everybody
large small Rich poor how do we find a
formula to make sure that each of us
does what
is required
in my small way I do and you in your big
way too
so since we are all users how do we all
pay together
and I think that that's a formula that
we have to find I've been thinking this
through a little bit and thought that in
tourism for example we travel across the
world 1.4 billion of us did so in 2019
we spent nine trillion dollars but in
the process we created carbon footprints
that are enormous
so a chief of us decide that we had to
pay something
for what we've done because we're a
consumer understood yeah what what do
British tourists who are watching
um this morning who were thinking about
coming to your wonderful country next
year how can they help you be more
sustainable well this is for example we
established the global tourism
resilience and crisis Management Center
because resilience is at the heart of
understanding how to deal with
sustainability and if each for example
contributed
small tip for example for each meal that
you have it's
to literally put back something and to
create a fund and I've been asking for
this there's need for this resilience
fund that will enable small vulnerable
but weekly resource conscious of the
world to have an opportunity to recover
and to recover quickly and to thrive
after disruptions I mean we're having
difficulties now all over floods are
happening everywhere hurricanes are of
earthquakes and now we have to worry
about wars and cyber crimes and so on
all these are disruptions that they
opened and in fact affect how economic
activities flow and the ability of
countries to respond so I think the the
call is not just a call now that large
countries put up money per se but all of
us can contribute and we can do it by
paying for our actions sure it's good to
talk to you Minister thank you so much
for taking the time to join us
um
absolutely I'm looking forward to it too
thank you very much today Minister thank
you uh meantime what's happening in
America well it's the midterms today uh
Biden has been warning of a risk to
democracy Trump has hinted at another
run so what is likely to happen to women
um who enjoy debating this sort of thing
of course uh um Scotty and Shola hello
to you ladies good morning Scotty of
course we should go to you first given
that it's at your territory Nashville
Tennessee is where you are this morning
what are the main issues that we should
be looking out for today
well while the Democrats are mainly
trying to focus and make this all about
life and about the Roe versus Wade
Supreme Court overturned a few weeks ago
the reality of it is the issues that
most Americans are thinking about when
they go to the poll and Republicans are
urging folks to do is first go to the
grocery store and see how much that it
costs more now for milk bread and eggs
and then on your way to the voting booth
make sure that you go by the gas station
and recognize that while prizes have
come down slightly we're still
increasingly more than where we were
even just two years ago and then on your
way to the voting booth they want to
make sure that you're safe and look and
realize is your neighborhood safe as
violent crime rates in the United States
have increased immensely over the last
two years and of course Republicans are
pinning this on the failed agenda to
keep Americans safe of Joe Biden so
between those three aspects those are
actually what are on the top of the
minds of most of the American electorate
at least that's what the Republicans are
hoping for when they go to the voting
booth today
yeah let me quickly add though that what
the Republicans have done very well is
to play strategy of distract and deflect
and they've done this by incorporating
racializing the fear of crime uh
fundamentalizing election denialism and
deliberately sabotaging reforms economic
reforms and other reforms that the
Democrats put forward to be able to help
Americans live a better life on a daily
basis so it is the Republicans that
voted against the inflation reduction
act if the Republicans that voted
against cheaper gas against cheaper
insulin against abortion rights our
European way against stimulus checks it
is the Republicans that voted against
baby you know formula voted your Voting
Rights Act marriage equality and so many
things that would have made the lives of
Americans much better I want Americans
when they go to the grocery store and
have to buy food at a higher price to
remember that it is a Republicans that
voted against it that made this possible
I want them to remember when they go to
the gas station they're paying a higher
price that it is the Republicans that
stood against the opportunity for them
to buy less so and what the Democrats
have not done as well is to make this
the topic of conversation I think the
Democrats thought at some point all we
just need to do is just to ride the wave
of um the public being aware of Roe v
Wade the public being aware that it is
the Republicans that have voted against
you know fundamental reforms that have
made their lives matter no you do not
fight fire when staying back and let
people just use awareness so you need to
Fight Fire with Fire and that's what the
Democrats need to do better and as I
said the Republicans have used this
midterm elections to become the ground
zero of election denialism think about
it a lot of the Republican candidates
are election denial it's unbelievable 22
candidates for Governor 19 candidates
for Senate 12 candidates for Secretary
of State and 10 candidates for attorney
general all have either denied the 2020
election or cast doubted it
um do you think now um Scotty forgive me
Scotty null Hughes that
um that Trump will run again
well I want to get to Trump but I do
have to say this okay you want to talk
about election denial you're going to
hear the biggest case of election denial
tomorrow morning when the Democrats wake
up and those races that have been
decided are clearly not in their favor
we're about to hear the biggest amount
of election denials and that's going to
be all the way from dog catcher all the
way up to the federal Offices like
Senator and and I love what show was I
appreciate her compliments but the
reality of it is she can get away with
that argument except for the fact that
it's the Democrats who are in power for
both the house the Senate and the Oval
Office so you can't blame the
Republicans because it's the Democrats
that have total power right now and
that's why we're in the state where
they're in which is why I do believe
that you will be seeing president Trump
taking advantage of the momentum of the
of tomorrow and going into as the hints
even went through the last 24 hours that
he was going to announce he is going to
probably take full credit for a lot of
the power being taken back in the House
and Senate despite them losing it during
the Trump Administration so yes I do
think that you will be seeing a trump
announcement coming soon but I also
think that also means that just gears up
probably for more prosecution coming
from the FBI and others who have been
trying to continue to make sure they
find Donald Trump and handcuffs being
led up the court stairs we'll see how
the two counter for each other makes for
great TV
oh my goodness I think Scotty you and I
agree on something though we agree that
Trump is going to try to come back to to
run again and take credit absolutely
that that is DNA but where we disagree
we just met a much right where we
disagree is this you saying that no you
can't blame the Republicans it's because
the Democrats are in power that's not
the point it is the actions that the
Republicans take with the power that
they have in Senate in the House of
Representatives they voted against
crucial reforms that would help the
American people so the American people
need to understand where their bread is
buttered and it is not with the
Republicans that's the point I'm
beginning about Trump let's make this
really clear if Donald Trump is able to
run again and potentially win and become
the you know the next president of of
the United States of America let's just
understand that this is an indictment of
U.S politics which is already a suspect
and an indictment of the American
society how can you have the person who
single-handedly incited the the biggest
Insurrection of U.S democracy in modern
history be able to run against run again
for office the person who is insured
that elections can no longer be trusted
at the very Foundation of U.S democracy
cannot be you know how can you have that
person back as U.S president okay guys
that's a good taster for what's going to
happen today hopefully we might be able
to chat to you about the results
tomorrow it's great to see you both
thank you very much indeed thank you
huge travel exhibition in London talking
a lot about travel not least because of
cop 27 and the Damage that I was
traveling around the globe could have on
the sector Alan French CEO of Thomas
Cook is with us now good morning good
morning it's great to see you how
worried are you about sustainable travel
we are concerned and and certainly our
customers are concerned and they want to
know more about what's sustainable and
what isn't the airlines are doing some
great work in terms of trying to make
carbon neutral travel possible
um hotels are doing their best to make
the stays in the hotel as carbon neutral
as possible and exposing that to the
customers and allowing them to you know
interact with the flights and the hotels
and choose I think is an important part
of what we need to do okay what is
travel looking like
oh going forward actually travel is
looking reasonably buoyant
um a lot of people didn't travel this
year I mean this year we had a a good
year but actually quite a lot of people
didn't travel
um I think the travel disruption put a
number of people off and I think people
who were concerned
um for medical reasons didn't travel and
perhaps the elderly didn't travel so
there's a lot of people who are looking
into next year actually want to get out
there and start to celebrate Landmark
events with friends and family go to
destinations they've been to in the past
so we are seeing it holding up we are of
course concerned about an impending
recession and financial pressures
um and I think people will be shopping
around I think we'll people will be
looking to lock in holidays early
um and probably looking at what
destinations are most cost effective but
I think in general we're we're pretty
positive about the outlooks for travel
cost of travel is prohibitive though
isn't it for a lot of people at the
moment particularly uh
fine cost of flying is going up we are
seeing that rising at the moment when
we're looking forward we're seeing a
small rate of inflation but I mean I
would expect to see that increase as we
go into next year more markedly so yes I
think it will increase I mean at the
moment we're seeing probably about 10
increases from last year as we look into
the winter flying season as we look into
the flight summer flying season I would
expect that to go up as fuel um costs
come on how how aware are we as Brits of
of sustainability just I don't know if
you heard the Jamaican tourism Minister
was just on the program and he was
saying one of the ways to help the
countries that we might go to wherever
it might be the Caribbean or whatever is
to leave small tips to help the people
in the country to get themselves back on
their feet again yeah and I think that
we are seeing more and more customers
wanting to get involved in what's going
on in the destination and help out
whether they can either either by
contributing financially or actually by
contributing their time while way and we
want to make that sort of thing
available to customers as they go on
holiday okay so what are your top tips
for people if they're thinking about
going away
um I think yeah yeah where are you gonna
go
I'll probably go to Croatia this year
um I think the top tips are look around
um lock in a price early
um and I think there's some great offers
out there at the moment and I think as
we come into January and February
there'll be some great offers available
um at reasonable rates
um I think the the price inflation may
come through later in the year okay um
but it is it is incredibly expensive for
a family of four to go away now compared
to what it might have been a couple of
years ago certainly before the pandemic
and we do have a cost of living crisis
with inflation in double figures you
must be worried about that as an
industry we are worried about that as an
industry and that's one of the reasons
that a site like Thomas Cook where
there's a wide choice of both
destinations board types and
um star ratios in terms of hotels is
important and we are seeing people
locking into all all-inclusive just so
that they can keep
um track of their potential expenditure
on holiday yeah do you find that people
still go into travel agencies or do they
do all this sort of stuff online now
um
this summer has been a difficult summer
for people to get into travel agencies I
think that for many holidays online is
is becoming more and more popular I
think certainly for some holidays people
do want to talk to people I mean
obviously we don't have any shops but we
do have a call center where we can you
can talk to somebody about what the
options are what's the best deal at the
moment
um as I said best deal at the moment is
probably Turkey
um everybody says turkey it's a good
deal and Malta apparently um Egypt is
also looking good into next summer right
um so yeah and if you're going further
afield
the Caribbean actually looks really
attractive
um
particularly
um places like well also in into Mexico
Mexico and the um Caribbean are looking
good um and I would expect the Indian
Ocean to start to open up next year as
well well that's from the expert ladies
and gentlemen our Alan French CEO of
Thomas Cook great to see you thanks for
coming in to talk to us much appreciated
thank you
um coming up in the next hour of the
breakfast show here on Sky News for you
this Tuesday morning what sort of bloke
is Gavin Williamson allegations in the
papers this morning that he told one of
his team to cup their throat and jump
out of a window he vehemently denies
that what's the government's saying in
response I wish you soon acts back home
again now having been a cop 27 we'll get
the very latest in just a moment do stay
tuned
foreign